20-mal häufig miley du bist du
eigentlich komplett hängen geblieben
darüber steht jahre lieben ich habe vor
genau zwei tagen ein video gemacht
kaffee abraten mitten im leben und es
kam überraschend gut an begab sich das
ganze mal viele wie jedes andere aber
das video hat echt schon was die leute
interessiert hat heute drei tage später
schon 190.000 aufrufe 15.000 bleibt aber
auch 1000 bis leicht gibt scheinbar auch
einige menschen die techniklehrer
marschieren tablett wirklich mögen wenn
wir die echten leben schlagen würden
würde die gerne umarmen mit ihnen bild
machen
ein autogramm hat und daran ist gar
nicht schlecht jeder kann weder mag aber
diese leute kamen dann natürlich auf
meinen kanalrohr die gewinner der
fixierten video ging kaputt gemacht was
sie zerstören und ja wir haben nicht
wirklich verstört in diesem video heute
möchte ich versuchen irgendetwas dagegen
zu machen ich weiß ich bin schon
komplett am arsch mein leben ist wasted
und ich würde auch ganz bald beenden
aber ich möchte doch dieses letzten
video machen und auf die kommentare
eingehen die zu bekommen zwar geht los
mit julian alexander zahlten der
schreibt du bist scheiße das ist ein
pranger
okay wir fangen ganz vorne an was villa
und wird den ersten drei buchstaben
sagen wie google macht wo ist ein
chemisches element mit dem element im
pool b und der ordnungszahl 5 im
periodensystem steht in der dritten
hauptgruppe alles klar
ansonsten schreibt wird du bist scheiße
das ist ein prank lieber julian was wird
mit dieser aussage bewirken dass es und
trank ist ich habe den titel gesehen ich
weiß dass ich krank es trenc du die
allgemeine entschuldigung für alles
mögliche kommt nach hause mama ich
musste sagen ich hab mir sechs in mathe
geschrieben und dann eure mutter du
kleider hut eure mutter dann sebastian
ich bin richtig enttäuscht von dir na ja
wo mamas liebling und dann auch mutter
ach so sagt es doch gleich mal also wenn
irgendwas am leben schieferplatten frank
julian das ist rang ist keine
entschuldigung dafür dass das zweite ist
und mega billig gefaked get to praise
mittlerweile dazu dass man die mega
belegt oder wie oft echte kommentar
kommt von mlc mlp und er schreibt ab
dadurch fest du kleiner [ __ ] aber
nicht nur dass seine schreibt auch noch
vor allem etwas über fehlen
467 es schick mir lange mal bereit sich
nackt mai liefert du kleiner ruhe 39 m
lfd
warum bist du so gemein zu mir ich nur
du klein warst schon persönlich sehr
getroffen hat aber dann auch noch 30
[Musik]
alles klar und geht direkt sagte walter
durch schreibt motti die bedeutung falls
doch die schnauze wenn du es besser
kannst dann mach ich nehm jetzt acht mal
so auf mich zukommt unterbringen kann
werde ich dann demnächst auf heck
polizei fängt nach dann bedankt euch
einfach beim achten dabei aber leute
gibt würden die gehälter würden es gibt
auch leute die janikowski einfach
scheinbar gestern am feiern waren ja
damals am feiern ich war gestern noch
gut auf achse janika auf die scheinbar
auch und er hat gesoffen leute er hat
gesoffen bis zum geht nicht mehr dann
kommt dann nach hause klick darauf ein
video kurz bevor einschläft und dann war
fehlte einfach die tastatur daraufhin
die zuletzt den kommentar
[Musik]
okay leute weiter im text es gibt ja
wirklich nicht ich weiß gar nicht warum
ich kein mache es gibt wirklich
kommentare die kann ich gut abgibt
kommentare die palette ab ja ich mache
ich eine weile youtube ich bin ein
bisschen was gehören ja immer älter
immer leute die das schreiben aber
manchmal trifft einen wirklich mitten
entfernt manchmal schreiben leute
einfach so richtig und langen abfahrten
im merkt aber dass leute die wirklich
schlauch ja nicht mit dem video
auseinandergesetzt und die schreiben
höflich war tony cripps nachvollziehen
so zum beispiel maxime lenk hat wenn er
schreibt unterm ein video die dümmste
was diese kommentare eigentlich mit mir
machen jetzt mal mythos dieser
kommentare kann ich besser mit geld
umgehen weil alle anderen kommentare die
irgendwie hält wenn dann einfach in
einen topf mit kommentaren wie du dumm
arschloch gepackt werden und die kann
man einfach nicht mehr ernst nimmt ist
eigentlich richtig richtig geile
strategien brauchen erst solchen
kommentaren des schreibens cape aus als
hättest du nicht geschlafen aber
ansonsten fliegt man zeug das recht das
letzte mal richtig ausgeschlafen sein
volk durch mich darüber nicht wirklich
schlaf wahrscheinlich echten bis hin zu
wählen aber in die wir gegenüber teams
beleidigt deswegen weiter sechster im
internet schreibt fresser selber du
blödmann oder später der nächste
kommentar zeigt perfekt wie degeneriert
manche zuschauer von lehrern und akkurat
sein können ja ich sage ich dass alle
degeneriert sind auch manche sind
einfach zum beispiel lockt l'oréal der
schreibt ich weiß gar nicht im video ein
werden soll was wird von kommentar ich
finde den frank kuhl ok und sie können
vielleicht was falsch sagen und halte
deine fresse deine videos nicht perfekt
acht mileys trauriges gesicht 20-mal
teufel smiley acht mal meine traurige
hinein
zwölfmal smiles gewicht 20 mal häufig
miley du bist bist du eigentlich
komplett hängengeblieben entweder hat er
meint das nicht mehr ironisch ja er
verwendet wirklich so viele smileys
wirklich der meinung dass das mein ich
zu verwenden wir gute idee ist gehalt
noch mal fest acht mal traurig wandel
teufels meinen zwölfmal trauriger smiley
15-mal teufel ein
du bist du hast dich so selbst große ich
muss dazu einfach überhaupt nichts mehr
sagen die leute motivieren mich
allerdings auch nur zum beispiel backing
deshalb fällt der sauber junge liegt
diese art tribüne und so sauber
ok backing eingriff mit einer
unterstützung ich weiß nicht ob ich
jetzt auch wenn löhne nennen würde aber
ich nehme mir deinen kommentar und
härter bewerten und ich mache weiter
leute wie du sind die mehr kraft geben
unvorstellbar vor ihn wacht morgens auf
und euer kopf ist einfach nur im modus
dass so ein kommentar abgespeichert und
der kommentar der erste gedanke am
morgen im kopf ist einfach verzaubert
junge fiktiven bühne
das wäre echt schon geil und hier immer
noch 1 kommentar bei dem wir noch mal
bitten ernsthafter sein können zwar
schreibt cybertron pvp es muss doch aber
nicht sein dass du ihnen dadurch noch
aufmerksamkeit schenkt also die sache
ist der typ hat schon genug
aufmerksamkeit jahr zwei millionen
abonnenten wenn ich mich über den macher
erste tropfen auf den heißen stein
derzeit macht überhaupt nichts aus der
hat schon zwei millionen abonnenten bin
ich mit 300.000 ein video bei youtube
nicht wirklich dadurch bekommen wir
nicht mehr aufmerksamkeit aber was sehr
wohl paket ist dass leute die upgrade
auch ein bisschen lächerlich finden oder
sie gerne darüber lustig machend meine
channel finden und wie er da so eine
gruppe formen können von leuten die
gegen alle vorgehen die keine ahnung es
steckt anti abholt army und wird einfach
zusammen lustig darüber machen kann es
ist eine win-win-situation wickeln
einerseits daran arbeiten dass die
offensichtliche fakes und bio sie hat
wirklich vielen leuten nicht gefallen
auch bisschen kritisiert werden und wie
konstruiert werden sollte sich mit dem
beziehungs selbst auseinandersetzen und
andererseits können erst zusammen
sparsam bei ich hab wirklich spaß daran
mir diese videos anzuschauen mich bitte
darüber lustig zu machen irgendwelche
wichtigen kommentare aufzugeben das
macht mir wirklich momentan am meisten
spart viel mehr spaß hat minecraft
zocken oder sonst mache ich finde es
einfach geil und deswegen würde so
weitergehen leute daumen nach oben
bis zum nächsten mal ab und auf trocken